Okay, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p.
Here's a voicemail from someone who is not
talking about Bernie versus Biden of Bernie
versus Warren Rather, but she is talking about
Bernie and Warren.
Take a listen to this.
Hello David Pakman and my name is Deborah
and I'm from Colorado.
Um, we watch your show and I just wanted to,
um, ask you to do a show where, um, you show
that Bernie and Elizabeth are the Dream Team
and that they both have a plan is, is very
similar and that if Elizabeth lands
hello.
Right.
Okay.
I guess that that is that, um, in any case,
yes.
You're, you're bringing up something.
So listen, Bernie and Warren are not the same
and I've made very, very clear that they come
from different political backgrounds on a
lot of domestic policy.
They end up in similar places on foreign policy.
There are definitely differences between Bernie
and Warren, so they're not the same.
But I have said before and I said at the top
of the show today, we need to make sure that
the critiques that are taking place within
the Democratic primary are not going to do
damage, uh, in the general election.
And I don't know ultimately who the nominee
will be and I don't know who the nominee is
going to select as the running mate, but I
think the narrative of we would be so much
better off with either Bernie or Warren is
a much better narrative than the increasingly
vicious attacks that I'm seeing from supporters
of different candidates against supporters
of other candidates.
And this is better than in fighting for sure.
Although it is much too early to be talking
about, uh, running mates.
We're trying, we haven't even had a single
vote cast so far in the actual Democratic
primary, but I, I like your attitude, that's
for sure.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get access to the bonus show by becoming a
member@joinpacmandotcomorapatronatpatrion.com
slash [inaudible] the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.